guys i think it's important that we rank
uh the wedding gifts that you guys gave
to me uh for this glorious day that i
gave to you guys why do you gotta rank
together why can't you just be grateful
for everyone
while we start with mark's gift
mark ruined his surprise
he wanted to give me and my wife a
surprise my wife he wants to give me my
wife
love it and um
so he messages me right knowing i'm with
my [ __ ] wife yeah right and he goes
uh hey can you guys give me a code to
get into your your building and i go
yeah i'll just tell emma to do it and he
goes well don't tell him it's going to
ruin the surprise and it's like okay
well that's already ruined right so i
think that this is going to be like this
big surprise
you know what i mean like oh my this is
about to be the most amazing president
if we're going through elaborate code
switching my god in order to get you in
the building to sneak in and give this
one how does it get a key to your
building why can't i just go into your
building my building doesn't have a key
grow up my friend
we got codes out here it's all
technology guys
if you knew how to give the code then i
could have just gone in yeah but i don't
understand technology my boy call shifty
shifty knows how to get into my building
i did and he said talk to andrew let's
go let's go to mark's gift this is this
is mark's uh mark got me um a bottle of
uh uh dom perrion champagne okay fancy
fancy the lenny kravitz edition oh fancy
uh i think it doesn't sound that fancy
lenny
mark what does an american rock musician
know about champagne
with a box i tried dude
it had the box what the [ __ ] is this
i see the bottle of champagne i'm like
whoa dom para this is probably some
exclusive [ __ ] and then i open it it's
lenny kravitz 2008. that's the best year
great year how do you know that just it
just sounds like it's a great year [ __ ]
does lenny kravitz have to do with
champagne no it is that that's the
that's the best it's the light up bottle
right no no that's the loomis i couldn't
get that you didn't get the light up
club
i was gonna get the 2012 though don't do
that i was out of the box yeah but i
couldn't get 2012 because the worst
vintage the the the flowers are nice the
flowers are very nice but super
anticlimactic give me the key to the
ability like you can just give me that
when i come to work and i'll be like
yeah they got us a bottle of water for
you it's for your girls yeah [ __ ]
y'all are that friends you got a lot of
gifts already i got i got well i got one
great gift no let's go through the gifts
yeah uh listen let's let's go through
the gifts this is great what were you
expecting what did you want to be in
your apartment this is miles kid
honestly i was gonna give you a cookie
back that was gonna be your gift cookie
back in your apartment
see this is thoughtful actually let's
start with the best the best gift so far
came from vala
valla edited this like whole video that
we played at the wedding yep right and
he had interviewed all like my friends
and emma's friends and our parents and
everything like that and then he like
compiled this video and it was just
really amazing it was a great job using
your skills and it's gonna be better
when you watch it if you watch it on
your own yeah because the at first of
all the audience stuff is gonna be
better but then it's like a private
thing you can share with each other
oh i haven't no okay well i'm gonna i'm
gonna watch that whole thing miles you
did something with pictures oh cause you
had the
disposable camera and then there's a let
there's like a note here that i don't
know if i want to read
will it be embarrassing to you i would
read it you can read it okay
okay okay to the couple who has it all
but needs nothing more than one another
oh that was beautiful that is nice dude
thank you he just did the guns up thank
you
white media
thank you for making me
uh
something at your wedding out of love
and laughter oh cry that's the way uh
thank you for sharing your day and your
people with me they're both
unforgettable i'm so grateful for both
of you and look forward to watching and
participating in the movie that is your
love and life that's beautiful and then
really cool pictures which i'll look at
later since we have to do this podcast
correct um why do you read mine though i
gave you a note i did you did give me a
note it was a great note it's very sweet
it was very sweet thank you your wife
i wrote you did not write it i looked at
the handwriting i looked at your
handwriting literally but i told her
what to write sure anyway uh
okay let's look at the other guess alex
dropped some cash which i thought was
very generous alex came through with a
good amount now he's came through with a
very good amount all right i saw that
wedding i was like he's going to need
this
you were right
you were very right
uh miles comes through uh shifty nothing
but i know how much he makes so that's
okay
f i got a shout out to fa f.a f.a came
through with very generous uh now let's
go to the people who hasn't given me
[ __ ] yet
dove what's up
wow you want me to list the reasons why
i haven't gotten why you got reasons wow
yeah reasons that's his gift to you
excuses
let's go
tell us why because you have more than
enough time to go spearfishing in the
[ __ ] bahamas where's my gift did i
have more than enough time where's my
gift a ceremony as your rabbi and how
much you save not actually getting a
real [ __ ] priesthood you really think
that you said we saved money not getting
you think a priest was gonna do my
wedding also do you have to pay the
priest
hey let's say one thing real quick doug
killed it oh
he killed it
most of our material hello welcome to
flavor two yeah
he brought charlotte charlotte ends up
doing the majority of the work
typical jew using a black man in hip-hop
for success
that was my little surprise then you
leor cohen
another thing then yeah we could just
jump right to it you [ __ ] crashed
well you brought your honeymoon to my
honeymoon and then what did i get you
the day after you got there a [ __ ]
yacht on christmas day so i got you a
wedding gift and you didn't get me a
yacht did you did you pay for the boat
you literally gave me the guy from the
boat do you think he paid for the boat
what is that bro yeah time and effort
thank you time and effort being friends
with your friends but they like me thank
you oren unbelievable this guy is
unbelievable
every nba jam that akash got us uh-huh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah great gift
by the way you know what you brought to
the boat can i just say what you brought
to the boat yeah andrew brought to the
boat a nice glass of [ __ ] champagne a
bottle it wasn't the kid rock don
perrion version it was real champagne
with a guy with a french [ __ ] name
lenny and kravitz and perry
which you got for free from the hotel
that i reached out to get you a hookup
on shout out pablo
so i'm just making you money on your
honeymoon
every day this is not what he's supposed
to do he think that this is not the jaws
off the club okay the point is where's
the gift okay i'm reading like being a
rabbi hold up hold up hold on being a
rabbi is not a gift hold up white people
weddings so you do fear a year to give
the person a gift it says it right there
on that list vogue.com
and well i just have to let you know
something what is my my wife
i'm just gonna let you know what is my
wife technically according to your rules
yeah ashkenazi she's soup juice
according to according to your rules so
when do the jews give the gift
babies they're going to be more jewish
than yours
you're marrying a chicks yeah you're
marrying a chick i did sure but i would
normally in that case give money but
then it's like almost like do i just
tell the business manager to reroute
which what you pay me back to you yeah
[Applause]
when my girl gets me something you think
it comes from her
[Laughter]
i'm buying me the thing
we all know this it's a recycling of
money well i could say that i give her
the money she buys me a gift to go babe
thank you so much oh that's good for
saving me the time going on essence dot
com and buying a gift you're right so
i'm gonna buy her whenever you buy the
clothes with essence right
triple s so because uh you got one fire
gift that's on your wrist right there no
we're not gonna talk about the game i'm
gonna get
we're talking about where's your gift
where are you you're just gonna not get
again no no no no it's coming
classless this guy's coming what kind of
pieces
this guy oh my friends my friend's
friend brought to you on a boat
in miami that's my gift
shout out to omar puravida yeah shout
out yeah we paid for that [ __ ] boat
with all the times we go to pura vida
saved your life and you're giving them
shout outs right now so it's not really
that kind of free yeah
shout out alexander best best real
estate shout out you useless okay what
are our guys get you yeah what did arcos
get me nothing open up your coinbase
wallet right now oh my god no oh
that was good because he set that up
today
so
i knew you would never buy any of these
altcoins on your own so a few months ago
i made an investment on both of our
behalfs it's up 40 percent i just sent
you half the money
this guy's obese oh that was good
yo you ain't [ __ ] bro
and your speech was nothing compared to
akash's exact little goofy ass jokes oh
we're all heroes
i'm robbed
get a new shirt that's all we have to do
new wardrobe for duff buy yourself that
oh my god
we're
doesn't even have an apartment he's not
committed to nothing
this guy's still living in a hotel
uh i'm not deflecting thousands do you
think it's because no woman wants to
commit to him that he doesn't want to
commit to anything else oh yo real talk
why should a woman commit to you if you
can't commit to yourself oh
[ __ ] bro
keep coming i can't believe you have the
receipts my friend i'll tell you what to
say you'll have a receiver my gift
that's for sure okay
um was there anybody else oh yeah and
then obviously the big gift um i got one
for emma too that's at that oh sorry
yeah yeah yeah
no no it's at the house damn boy this
guy went for and i like how you got me a
gift for me yeah yeah yeah that that is
class of course hey buddy come on
because you know me i know you exactly
yeah your wife enough to no i think that
counts as a good gift a gift that she
can't use at all
this is a private account she knows
nothing about
[Laughter]
all short cows maybe i'm giving all my
money we're going all in on evidence of
teas and crypto and they can't take
nothing from them these are mass
strengths
divorce our wives get that house
together
[Applause]